hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a market recap where i'm
gonna discuss of course amc gamestop but
we also had some strong moves on new
seed yesterday so i'm gonna analyze this
one at the end of this video because i'm
sure some of you are in the street are
interested i'm going to give targets i'm
going to give
support and resistances as usual so
let's start with amc and gamestop let's
get into it
[Music]
all right so
let's start with amc i'm gonna take a
step back because it's needed here and
as you guys know i'm gonna daily time
frame we did already one two three four
and i i don't know if we're still in
four so if we started the fifth but
there is one more move up to come that's
my take uh i'm really convinced we're
gonna see this move up not sure exactly
when probably before uh gen 22. so let's
analyze first the situation we have here
a nasty breakout guys okay let's be
honest i mean i'm here to do technical
analysis
so ta is here giving a bearish signal
i'm going to show you right away what is
the good scenario that still can happen
here but for now uh the reality is that
we have a breakout below this trendline
that had one two three four reactions
and five six and you can see the
breakout is without volume that's good
news but he's making a major move
through this trendline two days ago so
now it's been one more day on thursday
that we close below that level and if i
zoom in a little bit guys you can see
that this trendline acted as resistance
all right so this confirms i mean we
knew that already because we had already
five reactions
but
we closed below we then retested it and
for now got rejected so that's not
looking good for me
but
i have some good news the first good
news is that we have an immediate
support around 33 34 so it's quite close
and as long as i mean friday's session
is going to be very important if we
manage to close above that it's going to
be a fake out all right but on the other
hand if we uh close
below 36 many scenarios can happen but
we have support here we then have
another support just here so we have
basically a lot of support so basically
like i showed you guys in another video
we would have some somewhere horizontal
basis for the same triangle all right so
we would still be in a triangle and we
would probably rebound around 29 i would
say when the 200-day moving average is
coming so this is for me uh the
alternative scenario that is uh bearish
but uh i'm
quite bullish here actually uh despite
this uh ugly signal is when i look at
gamestop alright so just in terms of
market capitalization against up his
gamestop is 11 billion and amc 18
billion it's important to look at the
market cap because
uh the big market caps are driving the
flows right so
if one of those two has good signals
bullish signals probably the money would
flow in all of them
so
i don't have good signals on amc but
it's not too bad after breakout
consolidating just below and coming back
with a green day is very positive so
i mean it's mutual bearish on the short
term for amc and on gamestop we had plus
five percent on thursday which is very
good guys we found support on this
200-day moving average and we came back
to this resistance so this level is
important i'm really paying attention to
it uh this was already a level i showed
you guys uh some some of you were asking
me on this code uh it looks like
gamestop is about to fly it was last
week i said guys we have a second wave
pullback that is coming i would be
careful
and once again i didn't think it would
be that deep but i was expecting this
kind of pullback now it's been four days
in a row we are trading higher i mean
this day not really four days let's say
three days plus one and we have the
resistance level at 185 guys so if we
are able to close above that
today
it's gonna be really bullish for next
week i mean
this would be this is the scenario and
the counting i'm having for more than
one month so you know against that
sometimes i need to change those
countings because uh you know i didn't
find right away the correct one but this
one is holding well and if we have a
breakout here
i mean the third wave would really be on
the way and we would probably do
something like this okay
so
if this happens so what i'm saying is if
you close above 185
today on friday we'll probably run up
quickly to the 230 area which means 25
move up this is my take let's see uh but
we would be in the third wave here you
guys know that third waves are usually
very impulsive so this is looking quite
good to me so i really do hope we close
above 185 on gamestop today and above 36
on amc those are my levels if we close
above that today i would be very bullish
for next week now i want to show you
guys what happened on lucid it's a pain
in the ass we were following this one
for quite some time
uh you guys know that on discord we try
to share with you the best place and we
were discussing this
together with gabrielle that is working
with me on discord and
you know we were waiting for this
breakout all right we had here this nice
consolidation for one month after being
tested one two three four times we were
waiting for a close above this trend
line and it closed just below that's why
we didn't get in otherwise we would have
tried to get in uh but we're still happy
to see the strong move up because i know
that some of you were in this trade so i
want to analyze what happened here and
what might happen next so the first
thing you can check the volume guys 370
million shares exchange roughly at 30 35
so we are talking here about more than
10 billion usd trading on the stock
which is a lot all right so this is
bullish but here is my analysis first
thing when i have something like this i
check where what is uh on the option
market
all right so the very first thing i do
guys i come on this spreadsheet you guys
know this spreadsheet i built it using
bloomberg's formula and blackshot's
formula
so i'm getting the uh synthetic short
interest information for lucid so give
me a sec okay guys so and when i check
on lucid that is very important so first
information the total shot is 16 so this
is uh the sum of the regular short
interest as of 30s of september so i
might update that uh later but it's not
gonna change much and the synthetic show
today six percent here so the synthetic
shot is giving you a lot of information
because it's telling you where you have
gamma okay whenever you have a lot of
options on a strike usually when you're
going to go through this strike there's
going to be very impulsive moves so here
we can check where so you have the
option distribution here here is the
strike level so 20 40 60 80 you can see
that we have a strong accumulation of
options around the 30 strike
so
i'm not surprised that
i mean it's always surprising but
this is kind of explained this strong
move up of plus 30
is due to the massive number of call
options that were around 30 all right
and we went through this so market
makers option market makers needed to
buy on the upside now i check around 35
and 40 we are still have some but
definitely less than here so i would say
that the bullish momentum would
unfortunately fade on the upside and as
we have a lot of back holders here guys
uh from you know 30 to 60 many
will actually probably unwind the
position
and be selling around those levels so
uh we might
stay here a bit longer but
what happened here guys i had this
resistance level at 35 for quite some
time it was just the highest close level
we had in the recent past we went above
but we closed below so this is showing
me that in this area there are a lot of
sellers all right all this area is a
selling area uh bears and control in
this area so everything that comes here
is for me good to sell so for those who
are in this trade not financial advice
but what i would do if i managed to be
in i'm not in unfortunately is that i
would uh have taken profit i don't know
everything above 35 so starting at 35 40
45 something like this okay and i don't
think we're really gonna run up higher
but we have some good news about the
company right what happened is that so
basically there was some announcement
about uh some cars uh that are gonna be
uh bought by uh saudi arabia so this is
good news for the market and once again
this kind of news can give us momentum
but technically guys we have a lot of
resistance in this area and last thing i
wanted to tell you guys i'm gonna be
live on youtube for the first time this
monday at the open it's gonna be a bit
tough because as you know guys we are
managing some positions on discord and
it's usually at the market open that we
take all our trades because of the time
zone so i'm gonna try to do this
before so that i can be live with you
and discuss everything you guys want to
see uh we're gonna check the market
check the volumes check the the price
action and i will just answer all of
your questions the best i can so i hope
i will see you there i hope you guys
will be asking questions and once again
if you enjoyed this video please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're going to be the first
to know when i upload anything new and
stay close to show i'll see you guys